there aren't many heroes in the devil
all the time but if you look hard you'll
find at least one
young arvin russell played by tom
holland is everything that the other
residents of coal creek west virginia
and knockem stiff ohio are not
he's kind and brave always ready to
stick up for others and never backs down
from a fight
in other words he's the perfect
character for holland to play
just look at holland's first scene in
the movie eight years after a tragic and
bizarre set of circumstances left armin
an orphan and forced him to move in with
his grandmother emma his great-uncle
erskall and his stepsister lenora arvin
celebrates his birthday
on the surface it's a sweet scene but
like everything in the devil all the
time there's much more lurking just
under the surface not only is this
sequence full of grim portents about the
russell family's future but it's the
first time we see arvin fully grown and
get a glimpse of the man he's become
holland's performance in the scene tells
the audience everything they need to
know about arvin plays on holland's
natural strengths and shows exactly why
he's one of hollywood's go-to leading
men
despite all the amoral violent and
downright evil characters that come and
go throughout the devil all the time you
can't help but get the sense that arvin
is a character who's deeply inherently
kind
this scene proves it from the start look
at the party his family throws from
there's not much to the cake that emma
bakes it's lumpy and unfrosted
it doesn't even have real birthday
candles arvin's sole present is a
hand-me-down from a father that arvin
had a complicated relationship with a
relic of a brutal war and a very odd
gift for a teenager
but arvin doesn't complain in fact he
welcomes all of it
when he sees the cake as modest as it is
he smiles
before blowing out his lone candle he
gives his wish real thought proving that
his traumatic childhood hasn't robbed
him of all of his innocence
despite the baggage attached to the gun
he seems genuinely thankful
that's the best present i ever got thank
you and when lenora leans in for a hug
arvin welcomes it marking a stark
contrast to nine-year-old armin's
passive embrace of emma in the scene
before
arvin's later actions go even further
improving his genuine nature but this
scene sets the stage
all throughout the devil all the time
after this moment you never have any
doubt that arvin is a good person no
matter what he does
that's the power holland brings to the
character
young arvin played by michael banks
repetta is mostly reactive
things happen to him but he doesn't
drive the action after the birthday
party that changes
lenora is sweet but naive and emma and
erskal aren't getting any younger
when arvin blows out that candle he
effectively becomes the man of the house
his family is now under his protection
and he makes good on that dynamic as the
film progresses
i know you'd probably rather be doing
something else
you're a kin and i look out for each
other he knows it too
note the studied respectful glance he
gives his father's gun when he receives
it
this isn't a child who's ignoring the
responsibilities he's been given this is
a young man who's just been given the
power to kill and he's going to use it
wisely
[Music]
this plays out as the film continues
it's arvin who protects lenora from
bullies it's arvin who consoles emma
when reverend teagarden humiliates her
and when things get really bad it's
arvin who sacrifices his happiness for
the sake of his loved ones
excuse me preacher
got time for a center many of arvin's
actions later in the devil all the time
are shocking but they're all set up by
this early birthday scene
really you should have seen them all
coming all that being said arvin russell
isn't like any character that holland
has played before
when he's on screen holland is often
very high energy and he's usually quite
chatty
well i could have stuck the landing a
little better it's just a new suit wait
it's nothing mr stark
it's perfect thank you yeah we don't
really need to start a conversation okay
cat captain but unlike so many of
holland's memorable characters
arvin doesn't quit he doesn't banter in
fact much of the time he doesn't say
anything at all
oh i might have put my foot in something
that
wasn't my intentions again look at the
birthday party seen as an example
during the celebration holland only has
a few real lines
and yet not only does he carry the scene
but he's able to convey so much crucial
information about arvin through his body
language alone that he really doesn't
need to speak at all
the devil all the time is significantly
darker than anything holland has done
before and it directly tackles mature
themes that his previous blockbusters
only hinted at
it's a challenging movie and arvin could
only have been played by a competent
experienced actor naturally holland
nails it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite netflix movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you